-Hey, everyone, it is Nana Week
this week on our show,
in honor of my new children's
book, "Nana Loves You More."
We've been giving some love out
to all the grandmas out there,
all the gammies,
all the meemaws,
all the bubbies, the yia-yias.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, there's a lot of different
names for a nana out there.
But each night this week,
we're showcasing
a talented grandma on our show.
And tonight's talented nana is
Patsy Herb.
She's 72 years old and
she's from Brooklyn, New York,
and tonight,
she's going to show off
some of her dance moves for us.
Come on out here, Patsy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hey!
Patsy!
-How you doing?
-Thank you.
It's nice to see you.
-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
-Thank you, thank you.
-You look fantastic, Patsy.
-Thank you.
-Patsy, how long
have you been dancing?
-All my life.
-Oh, all your life.
Oh, my goodness.
Since you were a baby, huh?
-You got it.
-Yeah, you got in in you.
Yeah, I hear that you have
a very special dance
that you want to perform
just for us.
And I was wondering,
where did you learn this?
-I taught myself how to twerk.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Be careful, Patsy.
Roots, I'm excited to see this.
Patsy...
-But before --
-What? Yeah, sure.
-I have one more request.
-Yes?
-Anybody over 65 years old
and older,
please don't try this at home.
-Okay, there you go.
Thank you very much.
Whenever you're ready.
Roots, give her a beat.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What in the world is happening?
Alright, alright.
Okay. Alright, alright, alright.
Alright. Okay.
Oh, good. Very good.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much. Patsy.
Patsy Herb, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Patsy Herb! Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Oh, my -- That was...
-♪ Don't try this at home ♪